please welcome the beautiful taylor
schilling
oh my god you look so beautiful and you
are so beautiful and i'm so excited to
talk about
this show which is much more than a show
to me it's uh there's historical
references of pop culture and a time
that we remember so
well
the pam and tommy days
but this show has such an interesting
debate behind it tell me about the show
why is it important to you what is the
takeaway here
well for me
there was this kind of whisper of an
idea that pam anderson somehow was a
participant or
um
was involved in some way in this tape
being out in the world
and i was struck in in reading all of
the scripts that she actually is the
survivor of a crime and we haven't um
treated
we we haven't treated her experience as
such and we actually i mean there was a
a court decision that was made that her
because she had
worn a bathing suit and posed for
playboy which is not the same thing as
being an adult entertainer nope uh a
judge almost made the decision that her
body kind of belonged to the collective
yes and herself which is um
something that's kind of hard for us to
it's hard for me to wrap right it's
really hard to wrap your head around
it's hard for me to wrap my head around
that i i think there is such rich
conversation in this show about
where is consent in all of this
yeah well and i love that you're
bringing that up because consent you
know
for me personally i think consent is the
sun like we everything revolves sort of
around consent and as soon as as it's a
choice that someone's making
god bless when it's not a choice and i'm
not in control of my own body and i'm
not in control
of that my my own experience i'm not in
the seat of my own experience then it's
not okay
and so it's really has nothing to do
with the content
it has to do with the the idea that this
was stolen from her and this wasn't her
choice and in that way i think that pam
is a hero i mean she's truly truly a
hero
i love it no okay
you were at the forefront of pioneering
literally streaming as we know it orange
is the new black kicked off a lifestyle
that we didn't know before and now it's
the only one we know
million views it's a global phenomenon
what was that moment like for you when
you literally were a part of changing
how we live our lives
i had no idea i still don't i it just
was your producer that told me it was
105 million
views i mean i know when i go to you
know airports everyone's like i anywhere
i go a piper
you know piper exists but we thought i
thought we were making i mean we thought
that that and i am not being coy or
being hyperbolic with my like innocence
but it felt like that was a we were
making some kind of a web series when we
made that show your show is a testament
to literally
the changing of our lives
weirdest segue ever but i found out
something in your research and i have to
ask you is it true that you babysat
monkeys in middle school yes i had there
were monkeys that there were monkeys
slipped down the street
what what how what i don't like
babysitting a monkey
yeah well it's weird that i did that but
i would i don't know why i was how i
don't remember how i found out and i
don't remember how it was allowed
allowed to but they were there were
these monkeys they were capuchin monkeys
but they were babies and these people
down the street were like i don't know
what to do with our monkey i don't we
need somebody to babysit the monkeys
and i then would go and uh you know like
you make sure that the monkeys don't
take the diapers off that's like the big
deal were you like virgil don't do that
i was like look at me
so yeah i'd make sure i'd they would
they would just they were just they
would also like open the medicine
cabinet get
um ad if you weren't watching they'd
like get advil lick the sugar off of it
and then throw the
pills without the
so that's you have to make sure they
kept the diapers on and that they didn't
go into them
they didn't go into the medicine cabinet
okay oh weird i don't even know how we
got here
i just had to ask and i'm so glad that i
did and i have so much visuals in my
head right now um okay it's design week
on the show and i hear you're quite the
diy gal
what have you gotten into
well because i lived in very small
apartments in new york city for a very
long time so i can pretty much do
anything with like a nail
and a hammer or like sometimes i would
use like a
like a three pound weight as a hammer
um if i didn't have han i didn't have
hammers a lot i mean who has a hammer i
think if you don't have a hammer you can
take you know like a three pound weight
and use it as a hammer
i love that tip taylor schilling i have
been such a fan of yours i'm so excited
to talk with you about such a meaningful
interesting deep layered show like pam
and tommy which you are stirring in and
so amazing in and it's streaming on hulu
now and thank you so much for coming
here thank you thank you thank you
[Music]